what up space fam goes in here from
anime outpro back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story and we got a big one
here for you today with a betrayal with
the straw hats teaming up with cp0 of
all things to take on the seraphims
matchups we've been waiting for
desperately and much more so make sure
to stay tuned for this epic chapter if
you do enjoy seeing these weekly chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming
trailer parking with it and smash that
like button until you see fireworks join
the nakama if you haven't already by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all this chapter is called
labo phase death game so it seems like
Oda is trying his hand at that games now
which reminds you of stuff like squid
games and Alice in Borderlands let's see
how dark Oda gets though so by now it
seems clear something is wrong video
snails acting weird security systems not
working properly it seems pretty clear
someone's messing stuff up like Among Us
imposter Style we start out with
Pythagoras being asked to respond and
about that mysterious explosion we saw
last chapter that book is not too bright
here assuming it was an accident at
least for now a mysterious Shadow is
seen before Daft Punk loses the signal
to the feed place your bets in the
comments right now about who this Shadow
belongs to and we'll see who ends up
being right you'll definitely have
bragging rights if you get it right we
then jump to Zoro and Luffy the
connection has been cut and Luffy can't
hear to other voices anymore we see an
image showing how the towers here are
being destroyed we then jump to Nami and
Brooke Nami is looking with hearts in
her eyes you know classic anime stuff at
some Jewels but Edison says he can't let
her have them just because she asked but
in all honesty as everything falls apart
around them it's time for pirates to
grab some treasure just saying
thankfully Nami is of the same opinion
as me and brings the jewelry upon
hearing that they are man-made diamonds
Nami thinks that the future sounds
wonderful as you see money signs in her
eyes meanwhile Chopper and Robin are
traveling with Atlas Robin even sees an
artificial human in a pod very
futuristic indeed but looking at Nami
and Robin I gotta say that my personal
favorite thing about the future are the
outfits but anyways as it turns out they
figure out that vegapunk can create
organs and Chopper freaks out over how
awesome that is from a doctor's
perspective then cut to Luffy was now
coming into the control room where Daft
Punk is Daft Punk has lost communication
with Edison then more screens and Camera
feeds start going out he points out that
there is someone else inside the
laboratory we then jump to jembe and
Sanji who are with Stussy and Sanji
keeps gushing all over her I love Sanji
but he definitely takes things too far
when he says stuff like call me your dog
and she knows how to use him though she
says as long as he can find Stella for
her our boy usop and Frankie are
traveling with Lilith and York I feel
like Usopp will get some cool weapons
from this Arc and I hope this bubble gun
that Lilith is holding is one of them
the gun were told fires strong bubbles
that can reflect anything it bounces
things back so it's the perfect
non-deadly weapon and I'm sure it can be
used in a lot of creative ways too
especially with someone like Admiral
kizaru coming this group sees the giant
explosion and Pythagoras is seen on the
ground clearly hit by the explosion the
scary thing is that his head is gone
this is turning out to be like a murder
mystery Frank even thinks that the head
was blown off luckily this is the future
though and when something shocks Usopp
it turns out to be Pythagoras's detached
head with many legs and hands popping
out making its way to them and even
talking I love how much fun Otis having
with all this futuristic technology his
creativity really has free reign here
and it's great so back to the explosion
and we're told it doesn't look like an
accident but like an attack Pythagoras
says it was the darndest thing it'll
sound impossible but I know my eyes
weren't playing tricks on me the mystery
builds and he's told to just hurry up
and tell them but he keeps the mystery
going as he says I'm forced to wonder if
we made a grave miscalculation and then
he asks where is York and sees her with
little boa the Sarah fan York says that
Edison told her to hold her horses and
she should just wait outside as she's
admiring how cute little boa is the
seraphim unexpectedly starts using her
powers to turn her into stone Pythagoras
even told York to get away so he might
have seen the seraphim's attack even
though that shouldn't make sense as he
said again crazy to see seraphims using
these devil through related powers and
now that's one Mega Punk down so we may
only get Stella joining the straw hats
if this stuff continues and honestly I
could definitely see just the main body
joining them on their ship but we'll see
what happens we'll definitely miss out
on great characters like Lilith and
speaking of Lilith Lilith is angered
saying that the little boa seraphim
shouldn't be able to move on her own and
she tells her that she commands her to
stop little boy doesn't listen though
and launches a giant energy attack this
is looking like Dragon Ball at this
point like the Android Saga to be more
specific now questions come rushing in
did someone give a higher order but that
should only be POS possible for an elder
and they shouldn't be here yet was it
another Vega Punk which would mean one
is a traitor but why or is it something
else a miscalculation something going
wrong with the seraphims like them
thinking for themselves which was
mentioned before too we can't know for
sure but the mystery is definitely
intriguing me Pythagoras even says don't
they realize we're vegapunk when he sees
the seraphim is not accepting their
orders I also love how Frankie is
speaking like a reader here saying
didn't see this twist coming and then he
wonders if he should return fire then
they tried to contact Shaka AKA Daft
Punk but as we saw Communications have
been cut off this is getting crazy and
intense Lilith is freaking out telling
Frankie that he shouldn't attack because
they wouldn't stand a chance since they
designed the seraphim to be the most
powerful beings around that sounds like
an exciting challenge but aside from our
powerhouses like Luffy and Zorro I feel
like the others will have a lot of
trouble then we jump to said strongest
boys Luffy and Zoro they're being
attacked by S Bear and S Hawk my guess
is they will break off Luffy fighting
little Kuma maybe but more importantly
we'll finally get the Zorro vs little
mihawk fight something I've been saying
will happen and dying to see we got a
teaser before but here it looks like we
may actually get the more prolonged
fight then the crazy thing is that Zoro
says they were gunning for cp0 so crazy
who gave them that order while the other
one is attacking the vegapunks looks
like potentially cp0 as a whole may have
become enemies of the state at least in
the eyes of whoever the master
orchestrator is here I love Zorro though
because even though they're his enemies
he couldn't Let cp0 Die he says it would
leave a bad taste in his mouth if they
died in handcuffs and then Lil Kuma
launches another big bang like attack
it's that punk who says if they won't
take orders then they must already be
acting on a command issued by a vegapunk
and the Mystery deepens which one would
do that and why who is the traitor
finally that punk that deuces that
between the communication blackouts and
the barrier sealing them in it's
beginning to look like an elaborate plan
someone's trying to kill them and from
what he just said like I mentioned it's
looking like one of the Vega punks is an
imposter but which one do you have your
money on that's the question let me know
in the comments for now though Luchi and
Kaku have regained Consciousness and
they asked to let bygones be bygones for
now so they could form a temporary
alliance against the seraphims with the
straw hats Luchi says and it does make
sense if they don't backstab him that
they'll be more useful outside of
handcuffs Luffy and Zorro give them
funny looks of disgust and we're told
this is potentially an unprecedented
team up I believe they will be freed
because like Zorro said he doesn't want
them to die handcuffed plus it wouldn't
be the first time government officials
worked with pirates think GARP and Roger
teaming up against rocks or Blackbeard
somehow being helped by Kobe to take
down Wang ji former rocks pirate and
former Pirate Island boss it's a pretty
hype situation and I can't wait to see
what happens but I hope as I been
expecting to see Zoro taking on Seraph
and mihawk one-on-one we have so many
potential crazy matchups including the
possibility of Luffy having to fight
little boa which would be one of the
craziest ones for fans to witness or
even jimbei fighting his own seraphim
absolute insanity and I love it this
chapter has definitely picked up the
pace and now I'm not excited for the
next one definitely crazier than last
chapter and I'm thankful for that and
now that the Rock's Pirates are becoming
more and more relevant with even cp0
Stussy recently being revealed to be a
rock's pirate clone you won't want to
miss my new all nine rocks Pirates
explained video link on screen right now
and in the description where I go deep
into this hypest and strongest of pirate
Cruise in all of One Piece history